[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity Senate Republicans just released
a trove of bombshell documents
surrounding Christopher Steele's dirty
dossier according to the material
Steele's primary sub source told the FBI
in 2017 that the dossier was quote
unsubstantiated and unreliable and
that's not all sharyl Attkisson reports
these documents reveal that the
anti-trump leaks in a 2017 New York
Times piece were wrong nine times in the
same article it's it's kind of like a
weird theater isn't it
joining us now with more is the ranking
member of the House in telemedicine in
yes and the co-author of the new book
fallout John Solomon joins us gentlemen
thank you for being with us tonight
it is a crazy time a John Solomon let's
start with you because you know it
almost can become overwhelming sometimes
we get pieces of information that tells
us all the time that this was wrong that
was wrong that was a fraud that was fake
how is this now what does this new
information mean and how are things
proceeding with with what's being
released and what we can expect to have
come up
yeah listen these documents today
deliver a devastating blow to the
credibility of three central figures in
the Russia case the New York Times which
drove the theory of Russia collusion
that was false
nine errors nine substantive errors in a
single story they should retract that
story
Christopher steal the dossier his own
source disowned much of the information
when he met with the FBI either
Christopher Steele made it up or didn't
take very good records in was a lousy
intelligence agent and third you have an
entire example of the FBI knowing for
months that everything that gave to the
FISA Court was wrong everything and yet
they never retracted and renewed the
FISA application two more times you know
it's amazing I know representative
representative Nunez we're all waiting
for the durum well the durum report his
action when it comes to indictments
possibly etc but the American people
this is effective the legitimacy of the
government when we see this going on and
we conclusions we have to draw and now
we know everything we see show
that there was some kind of weird
collusion to do something bad to stop
Donald Trump what is it with everything
you've been through in this regard what
is your take on where things have landed
at this point well I think to correct
I'm not too interested in a Durham
report I would like to know everything
for the four plus years that went on
including even the molar investigation
but really what we want is we want
indictments we've made 14 criminal
referrals we have another investigation
that's ongoing and I would say the
takeaway that I have tonight John John
hit it on the head with those three
important topics but also we have
suspected for a very long time that
Steele had maybe only two Russians but
we believe they were actually kind of
real Russians but he didn't really know
them and the question is is it how was
it that Steele found the supposed
Russians when a man was able to use them
we've asked the FBI and the CIA about
these Russians I've said for a long time
we're interested in two Russians and
this won't surprise you they have yet to
allow us access to these Russians that
we now believe other than the United
States we're really we're really tight
here but clearly Americans are hearing
that very serious things they're
continuing to go on we clearly still
need the exposure of them both of you
are doing a very good job in that regard
and justice is coming I think it's safe
to say that gentlemen thanks for being
here tonight